can we go back for a moment for the
graph you were referring to and just
show the intensity on the side as you
mentioned yeah this this shows you what
you know this is what you're doing as
you do it you you're writing little
search sentences and you're putting
hyphens and then you're drawing a line
connecting them all but then when you
put it on the side you can see the shape
of your story and you can see where it
needs some attention you know where that
you know there is all these Peaks here
but no real valleys so it would be much
more dramatic if you drop some of the
intensity or you added less intense
scenes in here so that the Rises would
be greater etcetera and you know it
could be that everything is just fine
when you do this and it looks really
perfect but most the time you'll
discover that it's not a roller coaster
ride which is what you want you know
your reader to go on you want them to
should be screaming all the time
basically and then toward the end you
see the highest peak and then it levels
down yeah and levels down although you
know today's storytelling world maybe
this is not the right way to end the
story you know it might be better to end
on a higher peak sorry no no this is
this is just a made-up story that we use
as an example here yeah so but you
should that mean that's just like my
client Millie Mayer outlined The Grapes
of Wrath you sit and sit down with a
movie like jaws or like the meg that's
coming out in August from Warner
Brothers and and chart it and you'll see
how conscious the story is of these ups
and downs I mean people that they know
what they're doing directors are known
for their ability to do that and if you
want you know you want a crazy all-out
screaming ride go see Lara Croft or one
of their James Bond movies and you'll
you'll see that that's that's what they
tried to deliver to you and if you want
a more tempered ride where you can get
deeper into the story because you have a
moment to rest between Peaks then you'll
see another kind of story sorry I cut
you off but you were saying that
today's Peaks might end a little higher
would that be because of there's a
possibility of a sequel or yeah I mean
usually it's it's that and it's also
because we are - ever since the moment
that Star Wars hit the screens I'll
never forget that moment because when I
watched that movie I thought this is a
watershed in the history of movies we
will never look at movies the same way
again because the scenes were the
shortest scenes I've ever seen you know
they scenes before that probably
averaged two to three minutes but when
in Star Wars the seams seem like they
lasted six seconds or 10 seconds and you
could not see everything in the scene
which made you instantly fall in love
with the movie because you believed in
the world if it was so chock-full of
stuff you couldn't see it all you just
have to go see it again and I thought
this is brilliant
and it was a foreshadowing of the
attention span that we're now fully
living with we weren't quite there yet
when it came out it was a little ahead
of its time but it totally predicted the
world we live in now where our attention
span is just minut because we're being
bombarded by so many pieces of
information from so many directions
we're distracted all the time and you
know the text is ringing the phone is
ringing that the email was ringing you
know our head is ringing our eyes are
buzzing from you know somebody said
Americans look in 52,000 commercials
every day in a normal day and I think
that's true I mean if assuming your
commute to work and you're looking at
everything out there bus is going by you
know billboards etc so I think that
there's another example of a filmmaker
who understood the audience psychology
and who directly addressed it who
directly addressed that that's what he's
all about is grabbing your psychology
and playing with it and you love it
because nobody has done that to you
before nobody's nobody was making movies
that you had to immediately go see again
because you wanted to see what that
little gizmo was in the in the far
corner that you didn't happen to focus
on and now the scenes over and you're
all going out to another scene and you
missed that
so you got to go back and train your eye
to watch for that corner and you know
how that is you
you're always thinking next time I watch
it I'm gonna really watch this corner or
something this corner because I know I
don't have a chance to see it all and
that is really screwing with the
psychology of the audience love that
you